- You know I love closing the show
with something sure to make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
Bright yellow refrigerators are popping up
on sidewalks across Philadelphia.
They're filled with fresh food
and water for anyone to grab.
The motto is take what you
need, leave what you don't.
The goal is to combat food scarcity
and it's all thanks to the
community fridge project,
launched by the e-commerce
company, Mama-Tee.
You can read all about it
in "People" magazine's
annual kindness issue,
on newsstands stands today.
This special issue highlights
do-gooders all over the country.
We have the woman behind the
community fridge project,
joining us right now.
Let's say "Hi," to people's
kindness award winner, Michelle.
(crowd cheering)
Hi Michelle!
- Good to be here with you.
- Oh, you have a beautiful smile.
You just made me smile with your smile.
(Kelly laughing)
Well, how did you come up with this idea?
- Well, I don't think people
know that Philadelphia is one
of the most food insecure
cities across the country.
One in five Philadelphians
suffer from some level
of food insecurity, and I always wanted
to be involved in a
socially impactful mission.
I'm a past educator.
That was very important for me
to also provide an example for kids
to be responsible citizens.
And so the community fridges
was just a right fit for me.
And now we have 18.
- That's amazing.
(crowd applauding)
And thank you for being
an educator, by the way.
You're featured in "People"
magazine's kindness issue.
So what does kindness mean to you?
- Kindness means the world to me.
This project has let me know
that there are some
wonderful humans out there,
no matter how big or
small we can all help out.
And your help is unique to you.
I just think the main thing
is that we all get involved.
- Absolutely.
(crowd applauding)
Well, we want to thank "People" magazine
for bringing us this incredible story.
To read more inspiring stories
from the kindness issue,
please pick up the new issue of "People"
on newsstands nationwide, right now,
you're gonna want to check it out.
Thank you so much, Michelle,
for all that you're doing,
I'm liking your posts right now, right?
(heart dinging)
(crowd cheering)
(Michelle laughing)
- [Michelle] Thank you, Kelly.
- And that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, the go-to pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
likes to celebrate those
who create fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they'll be using their G2 gel ink pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you, that's awesome.
- Yeah!
(both laughing)
All right, thank you
Michelle, have a lovely day.